the question of what's going to give
more
important because quite often what
happens is that when I give the
message I give it people are scared by
it because it seems to suggest that it's
all over before we're in a position to
consciously try to pull ourselves up by
our bootstraps as it were right and the
more empowering message with this is
that we are more plastic than we ever
thought that in fact it is not a case
that a blueprint simply reads itself out
and that our genes long to replicate
themselves and use our bodies as a host
to do that it is not a story of that it
is a story of plasticity and as we're
coming to understand human developmental
plasticity we are understanding that the
things that occur early on in life are
foundational but that there are
developmental tasks and opportunities
for plasticity in our brains that
continue throughout the life course
perhaps at a diminishing rate but they
do emerge throughout the life course and
that that is potentially very empowering
for people